a barium enema examination or lower GI
series is an x-ray procedure used to
visualize the interior anatomy of your
large intestine or colon and rectum your
digestive tract consists of the mouth
esophagus stomach small intestine colon
and the rectum food travels down the
digestive tract in this order
the main functions of the colon are to
absorb water into the body change liquid
waste material into solid waste material
known as feces and store feces until
enough accumulates to be passed from the
anus as a bowel movement
abnormal conditions may develop in your
Cola such as colon cancer polyps
outpouching zuv the colon wall called
diverticula ulcers or narrowed areas
known as strictures
if you develop unexplained bleeding
abdominal pain or change in your bowel
habits your doctor may recommend you get
a barium enema examination before the
procedure you'll be asked to lie down on
an x-ray table a lubricated tube will be
carefully inserted into your rectum
a bag containing barium will be attached
to the tube
and the barium will be allowed to flow
into your colon
when enough barium has flowed into your
colon you'll be asked to try very hard
not to expel any of it while x-rays are
taken
a tiny balloon attached to the tubing
that carries the barium may be inflated
to prevent any barium from leaking out
during the exam
while the x-ray pictures are being taken
you'll be asked to roll from side to
side or to stand up this lets the barium
flow to different areas so that
sufficient x-ray images can be obtained
of your entire colon
after many x-ray pictures are taken
you'll be given a bedpan or taken to a
bathroom and asked to expel as much of
the barium as possible
a few more x-rays may be taken after you
have passed most of the barium out of
your colon because the small remaining
amount of barium clearly illuminates the
outline of your colon
after your barium enema you can go home
you will most likely be able to resume
your normal diet most radiologists
instruct patients to increase their
fluid intake for a period of time to be
certain all of the barium is passed you
will likely notice more gas than usual
and see barium in the next several bowel
movements that you pass